[Music]
welcome back to the game spot co-op
stage we have our last panel of the
evening thank you for joining us all day
my name is chasity and we're gonna be
doing a live version of Triforce I mean
it's always live but we're doing it at
e3 so an e3 version of Triforce so here
we go we've got Rob handler II and Peter
Brown thank you so much for joining me
today on the stage
tell us about Triforce if no one has
watched it before what do you guys do
and what's gonna happen today Triforce
was what a year ago when Zelda came out
yeah not too long we loved the game and
we decided that we wanted to have a
weekly live stream and I'd say the best
episode was one where we decided to have
let's play blindfolded and have the
other person direct us from one corner
of the map to the other and it's it
doesn't work it's awful and chaotic but
it's hilarious we're doing success we
did it last time so again like the north
east side to the south west side we
pulled it off in about an hour we have a
surprised video it happens yeah we jump
in yeah we should go right now what are
we doing Rob's gonna wear this hat he's
gonna play first we're gonna work our
way to the northeast corner of the map
and we're gonna stop at stables and
that's what people trade off oh you
gotta go you take those glasses off baby
you gotta call yeah I don't need it like
yourself right okay so I guess we're
doing it right now ready here we go this
is gonna be alright my out of the menu
great or a disaster yeah so I believe
you're probably pointing in the right
direction so just head forward okay you
know what you're doing am i spritzing
you are rinsing we're doing yeah we're
doing it we're doing it keep going the
desert is pretty uneventful but that
will change once we we get to a stable I
think I think I'm wearing my good stance
yeah you're running out of stamina those
okay good that's cool you got to keep
that rhythm you know like oh yeah it's
here if you want some stamina but you're
back so uh just in case we run into you
know some lizalfos or something
dangerous
you're walking into this oh wait did you
talk to any
further hold on wait turn on the
mini-map let me see the controller real
quick look at the mini-map are you whoa
okay yeah we're all over the place we
are all over the place right now all
right so let's get to what's going well
it's everything's going to sleep the Hat
on you're fine
this is great oh here we go so we're
thinking also live what was your
favorite moment of Triforce Rob my
favorite moment well arguably favorite
was when I asked Peter to put on we were
trying to climb a mountain I said can I
put on my rock climbing gear he said
yeah sure and instead he put on like a
Lazaro mask and I went on for about like
ten 15 minutes and then I started
hearing a noise like you that like makes
a squeaking noise when you walk all
right how am i doing it Rob that's where
I want it it'll nice to jump yeah that
was a cute little job we're not there
yet am i doing what I think is to the
right so you wanted okay keep going
describe it to me
you might become sunny okay so you are
coming up to one of those like skull
things that has no it has an encampment
yeah yes so I'll shoot them okay okay
yeah you just raise the alarm
that's okay you're not snowboarding at
all hello no no no no I'll tell you but
now abort now you are okay no go you
have no momentum though I know I know
okay
they know I'm here are they chasing me
no no one's chasing me you're fine we're
gonna make it you have about 40 minutes
to do this yeah we can do it I would do
this so get to the end of the map
Robbie's a pro Zelda player I guess he's
a pro so he's the best we have my steals
everything again yes
sick for shield surfing describe it to
me oh it's so beautiful you're going so
fast
so hard nice flip degrees go left go
left no more a little bit more sure we
do better than sure perfect Rob perfect
absolutely perfect Darren is yep yep yep
this is how we're gonna make our speed
back I turn to the left again turning
around right now you don't know what
you're doing okay go left like that
you're not turning it off
nope you're running right into a wall
and and jump off yeah just go so you've
encountered them all Duga turn to the
left a little bit as you run yeah just
keep running and turning left unless you
want to fight it but oh oh no okay to
the right a little bit
wait he's in a fight now open stand in
front of you I think you'll be okay
alright alright you want to surf again
it's it's time for the time whistle you
just shot five arrows at one goodness
how many hours have you played Rob -
it'd be honest really yeah be honest um
100 hours of breath of the smiles
I mean it's cuz I replayed it on master
mode that's you know what you could do
in 700 you know much time that is that's
a lot of time I did the math and it made
my time sink where am I
you're good baby just keep running
straight keep going turn to look like a
hair to the left but don't stop don't
you ever stop at no time can't stop
won't stop so if we get if we're running
out of time and running out of distance
know your minutes we'll get on the bike
well yeah but the last ten minutes
running it on the bike if we don't if we
have not made it already regardless
he's described a Sunnah you're honestly
I'm gonna just you're walking you're
what you're there your bad habit there's
some hills yeah you're fine
so what to get over a hill all the same
I asked you to surf seek mister once we
crest the hill we're gonna like it like
three seconds surf okay three two one
nice Mary gave me the right so you got a
tournament left again going left left
like that yeah okay
I look to your right sit don't run to
your right but look to your right look
here it is that right that is your left
that's 11 its way hard to do uh look to
your right okay
see we got there what do we have see
that lump in the sand yeah oh do I see
it cuz I can't see it wait so that's an
enemy that's hidden I don't think he
wants to go alpha let's kick his ass
okay all right all right yeah turn ya go
forward turn your right a little bit
turn slightly right to your right right
okay oh [ __ ] he's electrified well your
boat attack attack
yeah he's jumping backwards he's just
walking around keep going forward
forward attack for a sec go to the right
right full health yes attack Oh Oh God
dr. fector running forward I'll tell you
to attack run run run oh no no no
[Laughter]
all right Ella killed him
you need to turn to the left now to get
back on track all right do I need it 90
degrees no you're good okay 90 degrees
yeah a health there you go perfect
perfect all right
it's straight you have just over half of
your health laps hey you know let's go
right for game I'm very good
all right cool shelter yep shield sir
timing huh I'll try to get right now now
do it and turn to the left as you do it
a little bit
Robert what you can't serve for that
sheriff what no just keep going you're
kind of going slightly uphill so I
wouldn't advise surfing it am i running
a little bit a touch okay stop turning
back to the left okay
go forward nothing you're doing fine
we're gonna climb okay let's have him
climb this should I put on my climbing
gear do you want no don't yeah go for it
it's not much to climb okay yeah you'll
be fine go forward keep going all right
now it's time to climb on the climb jump
and climb oh I know your stamina okay
there it is okay good wait is he in the
right a little left left
you're done quiet that's some other way
other way completely around there you
there you go okay run forward from there
we you fell down that's good okay should
you climb this he doesn't need to know
so we can have him climb in and jump off
and sail with his glider okay nice it
does so nice it's kind of you're not
gonna make this yeah I don't think
you're gonna make this climb though you
have to climb it from different town
jump down a user volleys gale one more
there you go one more time you got it
all right turn left that's a little bit
uh you fell okay
use your volleys gale valleys go forward
we should have used this for the last
one last time we try this I would have
just Rivoli's gale like the whole thing
we should check the map soon and see
what the heck stable is where we at
okay so there's a stable to the to the
left about ninety degrees
we haven't go to the second one that's a
little bit further out yeah let's go to
the second all right so keep going
forward you're gonna want to move to the
left a little bit you're heading north
what northeast right now you want to
head north good yeah yeah yeah
how you feeling fine I have no idea yeah
just keep going hmm
you're lucky cuz you're starting off in
an area where there's like basically no
enemies
yeah there's no enemies here you're fine
it'll get here all right
describe it to me otherwise you're
running across a lot of sands
am i running or gliding like lag hmm
you could probably could surf this if
you wanted yeah he could surf yeah haha
he's got tricks it's run just run don't
even fight him okay go disco you're
coming up on a cliff so you want to move
a little bit to the left to not try to
climb it a left go left now go forward
forward
go straight down slightly right oh yeah
a lot right a lot right a lot right
there you go great now I'm gonna turn
left again
turn left again yeah left left left it
one more time there you are and go
screaming I'm like kind of terrified if
I take this off and we haven't made any
progress we're getting to the good stuff
right seriously just been like a lot of
desert and that's eighth of the way
there man hell yeah absolutely I check
the map again I want to see where okay
great yeah you went turned 90 degrees to
the right you're like get out of the map
Oh halfway there would you say you need
to follow this path I guess a pastry
almost halfway yeah all right so you'll
be coming up on a stable and probably
like I'm you know another 30 seconds a
minute of running there's a yoga guy you
can
gun he's gone he's gone just go turn
right even attack that's good I locked
on no you're gonna turn to the left lat
it's just run yeah they kind of left to
give up eventually ha my good no just
run run whoo I heard him shoot what is
happening you got him
turn all right go straight damn right
nine degrees Gilligan
go back say Jamie turn to the right all
right right again right again right
right just drop all right it's important
to fall like that elections were giving
you I can't emphasize that enough
yeah you're climbing let go let go I
forgot I let go okay no I'm not really
dog walk backwards backwards walk back
okay then walk all right now go go to
the last night forward no no drop down
drop down drop run run run so you've and
drop hit be Sulekha hit be hippy hit Bob
you're climbing I implore you to hit B
okay thank you and back up go backwards
okay and now turn right turn go far we
go forward you know reorient the camp
all right yeah okay let's do it again so
90 degrees to the right there you go run
forward you've done it I am so proud of
you we got through there
turn a little bit to the left left I can
see the stable you are so close your
nightmare is almost over
want to hear cast
all right take it off you've made it oh
there you go this table all right you
did it all right
proud of you oh god I'm terrified I
would be too look maybe this is all
you're gonna be fine time okay
you did it in in 20 minutes should I
need some food yeah definitely shot all
right I'm gonna get some food hey you're
cheating hey I need food just eat the
food you're fine give me the banana no
eat a sweet meals on a stick
you got some meals is this your switch
there's a lot in there okay okay oh oh I
got you I got you I guess all right all
right you're unplugged do you want to
plug back in no we're doing it now
you're good baby just go of it you're
fully charged oh man this is kind of
nice but no put your sword away sprint
hell yeah yeah keep going yeah you got
to run fast beetle you ramp it right
past your left slightly likes yes left a
little bit
what's the button to focus the camera is
it the L yeah L trigger yeah turn around
and reorient 180 degrees yeah go still
go forward go forward yeah yeah you're
good now slightly to the left
[ __ ] drop drop be okay it's 90 degrees
the left reorient reorient shield nope
trigger oh all right you're good okay
okay right turn right yeah run the left
slightly left left left left slightly
insanity from the left right
you're going to sprint sprint thrown
away from them a little more to left
okay yeah you're good okay
go straight no I try it slightly right
right yeah
I keep running yeah you're good
slightly right keep running oh don't
forget you guys run run
keep going volleys Gail and just bounce
out of this if you want to right right
run more right more right more right
drop drop
nine nine degrees right straight yep
walk left
thank you reason left yep rent nice
good you're a Canyon right now yeah it's
a nice day it's beautiful another lovely
day you're right just keep running
just do brown and gold a little bit left
more a little more
yeah you're doing good back to a little
right all right don't throw it back
around to it all the way around the
oneworld right slightly right yep keep
runnin yep little more right yep hey
chi'lan okay
ooh a nice breeze is cool breeze left
left drop down drop down B I was gonna
turn to realize Gail okay oh do you
wanna yes good
all right oh yeah you're doing it let go
oh yeah all right - you probably scale
this yeah you probably n okay I have
some backup stamina if we need it oh
yeah you got this jump dude yeah yeah
mm-hmm of course you've got the backup
salmon all right yeah all right boss
boss now just climb hold on wait boss do
a start right
yeah we're gonna need some salmon I
don't know if you can do this can you do
this I don't know and pause baby good
menu okay go to the right oh yeah yeah
down one and then to the right yes eat
eat nice back out climbs okay jump
you're good look at that look at that
he's doing it all right all right it's
kind of close but we're not gonna go for
it you're climbing a little bit more
climbing there you go nice is he going
in the right direction should we check
the map yeah hell yeah
oh we're in the resurrection all right
dude chillin all right like this back
out all the time go straight go straight
rym going exactly right the direction
that you need to go yeah it's lovely
this is looking really good I got sky
thank you
easy on the salmon are you gonna stand a
fuller out of stamina no you're good now
you're back in it in it to win it
I feel like there should be enemies you
know what
not yet climb up oh do it again okay
when you go forward you're gonna hit a
canyon no no like it's not is that a
cannon forget it I thought was a canyon
knows it's a you should do it
hand glide but you're good oh there's a
bridge oh no there's a puppy
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're good we're fine you can stop you
can stop attacking you're gone you fell
farther than where he was I know you
left climb this yeah okay you're keep
climbing yeah keep going
does he have enough stamina yeah yeah
this just climb oh is he's runnin low
what's up oh just eat we have no more
salmon oh oh I see there's one more
we're good keep going jump yep
chilling hoop jump mm-hmm again one more
jump climb and you did it all right now
you're gonna be climbing again pretty
soon you go clan kick is that yep
Piggy's ass yep nice work nice work
all right it's done yeah where am I now
you climbing I can jump um where are you
you're in the desert it's night don't do
that no jump you're not jumping anymore
you probably shield surfing a bit I
forget how to service you didn't she'll
Serapis boobs you do el and then jump
and then a hey oh my god a bomb okay run
sprint hey hey hey nope okay
turn around no that's good move actually
thanks straight no backwards
oh you can't reorient when you're
actually hang glider really yeah I don't
think some I still hang gliding yeah
we're you know you're going the exact
opposite way oh no all right land oh
wait Oh miss me but no you're good
you're good you're fine okay ground
shield for that way put it away okay hey
girl
alright now turn around and reorient yep
yep sprint yeah when I say hand glide do
it alright hey what ya sport yeah a
little bit to the right slightly right
yeah keep going straight looking really
good yeah this looks great it's really
good great a little more alright yep yep
yep a little more a little more
yeah or you could be climbing in the
best be climbing and you're climbing
let's jump it nice okay now stop you're
on a like I was like a narrow path so
yeah go off so go left cool with it you
can fall off this okay yeah walk
straight right left left left
stop I know I turned around to save my
skate now go to the right night 93 let's
attack attack attack
attack attack keep attacking keep it
[Music]
orient yourself perfectly straight
sprint really go straight it's important
a little bit to let me here no we're
fine gonna turn back yeah okay back to
the left a little bit slightly I'll stop
this up a little bit to the left
yes go straight yes but be careful
well don't stop again let's kiss stop
straight attack
yeah yeah jack now attack to the right
so tap to the right no you don't know 90
degrees right okay don't sprint just
walk and slightly go to left yeah yeah
bone bone guys salt nice good you're
getting old it get ready
sprint sprint got some mob ones but
don't worry about that you just keep
going just keep running past him you're
doing really good here's giving good
instructions alright does he need a
climber
I'll let goes around this um keep what
straight maybe you got another volley
left oh you totally do oh yeah I got
three all right do it
send it let go straight yeah and you're
climbing jump go up up keep going up
you're almost there
I want to say you're better at this than
me Peter you're really good at this I
have to say anything you just play a
baby let's just keep going keep going
it's Prince yeah oh damn here at the
next odd angle I can glide oh you're
good keep my straight so we're like
pretty much of the next are we supposed
to go down this is nice yeah this is
good we're pretty much at the next we're
at our favourite stable so how how far
are we across the map not that far yeah
well this way we'll get to use the
motorcycle yeah yeah yeah half an hour
half an hour keep going straight you
want to switch it's up to you man I can
keep going yeah let's keep going and
alright pause actually Matt oh he's good
you're good yeah so just go to the right
book it book it where am I now
to the left little bit more left left
it's morning the Sun is rising grass is
swaying in the winds
man you're climbing a tree let go top
just attack it forget it doesn't say you
chop that tree down but did I walk
around attack
yep yep yep attack good all right go
straight go straight
that's great Oh water go to left a
little bit
we're probably gonna have this Brant
we're have to swim this you want to yeah
okay all right go oh right nine degrees
I think so actually pause go to map
sorry Matt yeah yeah well cross it there
so just go straight till left little bit
boat well yeah
go this way first we're gonna go around
now you're good keep it straight dude so
like near the water but not quite in it
Pahlavi's gales ready let go salmon
octorok he's just gonna be annoying
let's keep going they've got really good
range though they do there's nothing I
can do so I try to shoot him with a bone
area yeah he's chilling attack attack oh
yeah got it
that's a little bit what was that yeah
just cries who's a choo choo you wrecked
him thank you
okay you're kind of put on some water oh
oh no what happened so fast
that's it keep it on go straight
yesterday climb up climb back up you're
in the water right turn around
[Laughter]
alright yeah you're good yeah you're
good go to left little bit go left
yeah go go forward swim
swim punch here almost they pushed you
right in the water was really great
those moocher you're good rocks are we
going the right direction
heli yep okay all right straight
straight sprint sprint you're at a
sprint but whatever out of sector it's a
nice day you're good it's a really nice
day you're missing too hard grass it's
very nice
am I gonna run straight into Hyrule
Castle keep going
I say we get on the bike now yeah we
have 23 minutes you want to get on the
bike now yeah we have 23 minutes do you
think we should get on the bike yeah all
right let's get on the bike Wow
I just want to see it how do I do that
okay all the way yeah you know that's
right all the way right keep going go on
keep on keep on there it is got it oh
right
was it a oh no yeah uh and then do a
okay okay all right okay walk forward
yeah more a little bit more a back up a
little bit Oh go left go slightly left
okay
Hey okay and then again it Hey yeah yeah
right am i riding hey you're on it get a
whole day
okay whole day down all right now you're
riding well we're gonna do raagh rest
here we're doing it this is very
exciting
now this is slightly the left oh [ __ ]
right a little bit go slightly right
keep rowing
more laughs laughs laughs laughs let's
left left left left right Pete are you
all right all right left back laughs
again whoa
[Laughter]
sprint sprint sprint come on the bike
anymore you just have a nice red dot on
the back of your head
[Laughter]
this is hard right right go right
straight straight sprint sprint sprint
keep going up
climb up run right hard right hard right
hard right yep run straight left you're
doing great you're avoiding all of these
blasts from who from your best friend
all right Wow Peter who you just
defeated a guardian
I am so impressive all right let's get
on your bike that was amazing do that
again not gonna bike stop take a little
breather okay your salmon is actually no
go straight or yeah okay summon it you
had it summon that will use your room
yeah hey hey walk and get on walk
forward walk forward eh all right go
right 90 degrees oh yeah hit a door
accelerate go it's slightly right okay
right holy [ __ ] you're out get off of
the bike but to feed it you gotta feed
your pike all right all right go to the
left what do you feed your bike um
monster parts right a couple keep going
no no no
oh I said right tonight this is going
yeah you did go left go left keep going
left more left left left hit left go one
to the right this is give me one of
these one more one more
all right set select it down one yep
select Hey all right back out a fuel oh
nice pause okay one more though so do it
more saving a and then one down down hey
let's back out I can't beat it today we
did it yeah a giant ancient cores very
expensive but desperate times desperate
measures so get back on a you're doing
it dude accelerate gun wait does it only
do that much fuel are we gonna run out
again that would suck yeah we're like an
let it can do the controller and you can
be a 1 19 minutes I'm really surprised
yeah we got a pretty cats and I thought
those would do alright
I was wrong get off the bike again is it
out of gas already yeah what a beauty
real quick sure yeah that controller is
really warm because I'm so I'm imagining
like a hundred people in the audience
yeah and they're all yes they really
like it why are you just feeding it
random crap yeah cool no motorcycles
it's totally worth it alright Hey whole
day ain't it there you go go straight
yeah now this is podracing no this is do
a little jump
why turn owner out there at around 100
180 turn around yeah I ran out left
why did tell the jump on the bike okay
let's just turn your bike back on so why
don't you um do it the rune again
yeah okay hey hey wait a little more
lolly left hey hey holiday and you're
playing it and going straight Wow okay
habit all right laughing okay is he
going in the right direction
yeah okay just keep going moving more to
left slightly left slightly left
slightly left you're good okay go
straight out straighten out let right
right turn out to the right
the more the left left that's right yeah
you're it's great
you're good smooth sailing smooth until
you hit this tree right now yeah you
fell off I'm sorry
laughing left okay attack Wow good one
all right I turn back around know what
direction right 90 degrees straight out
and straight there we go
got it run nice dude what's up with that
bike running out of fuel so fast um I
don't know it's it's ancient Guardian
tech not very reliable okay keep going
this is looking really nice Peter so
yeah down slow down stop I'm really
trying to imagine all this don't win
that water it will now go now just walk
straight don't sprint Peter yeah attack
attack attack yep he's backing up yeah
Oh mom yeah let's go straight and walk
straight don't strain this walk walk
straight oh you got hit by a rock yeah
yeah just go walk walk that's great this
is fine all right he's getting pelted
your controller might be vibrating right
now don't it's fine you've got plenty of
hearts you can survive this week go
straight or five slightly left and
you're climbing all right you are
uh no you're sillens Miley laughs yeah a
little bit he's got range that will ya
really there right slightly right right
yep
they're live trees here that's fine
right yep mm-hmm
right slightly right straight okay this
looks good this a little bit to the left
left a little more left straight a
really dense forest right this nailed it
you're at the wetland stable you're at
the next table
cool all right I'm very impressed whoo
that was good where are we I think we're
like halfway oh do you look yeah that's
pretty good
that's pretty good enough time we have
yeah we have roughly you guys give good
you didn't we came across two Guardians
and you didn't take one hit from chasing
you all right all right you got about 13
minutes okay so yeah remember the trick
that I you have to like straighten the
camera out after you turn right yeah
okay so turn a little bit to the left
straight left a little bit more you get
a jump over a fence there you go okay
just run forward
I like our chances okay yeah you wanna
move to the right true do bike now go
slightly right should we do the bike
though okay yeah do the bike okay
summon that it I know right go slightly
left on it yeah your bow your bra degree
C I go slightly left slightly left left
okay really hard to the right hard right
hard right hard hard hard hard keep
going right right sure
got it not slightly left okay go the
right slightly right right
oh shoot let go go just go past them go
turn to the left as you're going not too
hard just enough keep going yeah yeah
yeah yeah perfect all right slightly
left straight yeah everything progress
you know we might be able to do this
well I think we might do you might like
what we went through was I think I want
to say the toughest part slightly to the
right straight straight left left left
left left
okay you're good when the right right
right okay okay stop stop stop let your
bike fall okay slightly to the left and
drive forward and that's okay straighten
out it's right now right sorry that's
right correct
yeah okay he is gonna come up to a
bridge somewhat soon yeah sick moves
dude right right right hard right hard
right hard right hard right hard right
okay so you're you need to be a little
bit cautious because we're coming up to
a bridge that's going to be a 90-degree
slowdown reverse am i reversing be be oh
you got off the bike maybe we should
just have him not be on the back yeah
okay all right so we're get the bike
okay going a little bit to the left
straighten out run walk walk forward
right to the right don't forward turn to
the right right okay straighten and run
forward go slightly left go straight run
sprint oh my god Oh
run run but to veer to the right a
little bit run where right now go
slightly right perfect for it oh great
gonna be fine everything's fine maybe -
maybe - boys very soon I'm fine you're
good you're good that's fine
all right let's check out the map real
quick I need to like get an idea we can
totally do this all right get out of
here and just run ten minutes left
run forward run where the bike the bike
is dead
winged dragon bring back to life you're
fine for now you're fine for now you're
gonna climb a series of mountains I want
you to use your volleys Gale so we can
get over them quickly
here to the right straight now and go
straight yeah good nice work you're
avoiding a lake that's to your right so
just don't
just grab it to me you were coming upon
a huge mountain with a lot of little
things to climb so it's not just a
straight shot so I want you to stop
right now stop you turn around 180
you're right about 90 degrees okay
slightly to your left and then use
Rivoli's Gale and fly forward there you
go
Dolly's gale dude try it again
straight straight now your camera and go
forward yeah all right okay
laughter near left a little bit left
okay you're good straight sprint you're
gonna end up having to climb if I'm
running against yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's good you've actually like found a
weird path through the mountains yeah no
no this is this is working it's rent
you're kind of climbing yeah that's okay
left yeah it's yeah turn to the left
yeah turn left stop down it's flatter if
you turn left okay left left straighten
out that's right go forward right yeah
turn right
I think you use the other rubber valleys
Gale right now to do that use it right
now yeah
perfect okay go for it for card card--
forward and you're climbing climb up
you're gonna jump while you're climbing
so just do that
climb up jump jump and you're good go
forward okay to your left head to the
left that's not too hard cut back around
half that to the right a little bit more
right right there you go forward head
forward good jump yeah there's a fire
bat up you're good Ian in center
yourself or you can do the bike I do 180
you're facing south so you do face north
there you go forward there's an emu
who's gonna attack attack attack attack
skeleton things all right you're good
slightly right yeah drop down turn
you're right down turn your degrees and
run just run
don't attack are you climbing again
he's like a precarious position where
it's like you have to be just so to not
climb yeah that's okay jump to get to
the top of this cliff yeah man we got we
got eight minutes Rob okay stop turn to
your right ninety degrees please and go
oh [ __ ] I got it go for it you can get
to the top of this mountain and then we
can do her volleys Gail from a high
vantage point and we can get really far
okay good turn your right and keep going
straight a little bit to the left
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you're sliding
all the way down no we do Saturday
Robert let's check the map real quick
and just see that we're working at oh I
feel like oh no did we great somehow she
would just make a mad sprint to the end
without the mask yes I pulled sure why
not we got like five minutes go for it
do a rob take off the Hat take off the
Hat make it happen this run for it
you made you got pretty far not pretty
for you you have dang it all right
without the blindfold you have six
minutes go for it it's pretty easy yeah
the problem was in this area you were so
close to either running or climbing
every time that it just got real
dangerous yeah well we kind of figured
it when it happened but was worth a shot
it's not it's a difficult challenge
pretty good in an hour you got through a
lot of that map hey we're going right
yeah man this games so good it is it's
amazing I was kind of hoping for like
more DLC but yeah
what do you think's next what's the
what's the next Zelda gonna be is it
gonna be just like this you think I
really think they're gonna try to make a
3ds game using sort of the concept of
mixing and matching elements that they
did in this remember that prototype they
showed up at GDC you know Nintendo wants
to keep the 3ds relevant and a Zelda
game might be the one to do that if they
can actually deliver that demo they made
or at least one similar to it you know
you'd play it yeah I would play I see
yeah yeah just like a 2d Zelda with that
mixing and matching of elements and
spells sure the immersive Sims stuff
panicked more Bravo good point for like
Metroid Prime it's like an underground
system just like this you know I mean
with like tunnels oh yeah that's what we
were talking about right like yeah it's
back like this world but with the yeah
you could just find I should be running
you now have four minutes hmm
we had a good run we did this by what do
you think what the bike I always felt
like it was so it was cool but it kind
of changed the game or like a weird way
oh I mean like that you know what I mean
like you just I kind of like we ruin the
idea of a first I guess saying
I guess you don't have to use it I like
to think of it as like a nice that's
gonna mix things up once in a while yeah
all right so we're gonna wrap this thing
up in three minutes so that we can say
goodbye to the audience and tell them
what's going on on the coop stage
tomorrow yeah what's going on tomorrow
tomorrow Thursday we have hop lip and a
jumps Jared Petty will be joining me on
the stage at 12:40 p.m. here and then
we're gonna have kind of funny coming in
at 2:40 to 6 p.m. with one break when
we're gonna have Cory bar log and Jordyn
vogt-roberts on the stage talking to Tim
and Lucy about anything they want really
so it's gonna be a real that's gonna be
a good segment that that is coming up at
4 o'clock tomorrow and that kind of
funny comes back again at 4:40 to close
up our show and then me and Lucy and
kind of funny will close out the show
right around 6:00 and that will be the
end of all of our e3 stuff awesome well
thank you for joining us today everybody
yeah thank you guys show your support
fives fives I'm air fine air five all
right thank you guys for joining us
oh good game spot for all your III stuff
love you guys thank you